[Music]
[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
now he's teased it out on social media
we're going to hear it for real today
the prime minister's former top
advisor dominic cummings preparing to
give evidence to mps this morning about
the government's handling of the covet
crisis but
how damaging will it be we'll ask the
transport secretary grant shaps
and the shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy both on the show today
also this morning the best-selling
author who wasn't diagnosed with autism
until she was 39.
now she wants to help others come out
and take away the stigma
[Music]
[Music]
oh plus takes you back doesn't it with a
long-awaited friends reunion about to
air we speak to the man who composed the
iconic theme tune
for the show it is wednesday the 26th of
may
the prime minister's former chief
advisor dominic cummings prepares to
give his side of the story
on the government's pandemic planning as
tory mps speculate about what's coming
i told the prime minister some time ago
that if he
didn't get rid of mr cummings then the
likelihood was that mr cummings would
bring him down
vaccine roll out to over 30 year olds in
england but what's the latest on the
india variant we'll speak to the
government's vaccine advisors on the
program today
a new video from belarus the girlfriend
of the journalist taken from a ryanair
jet
is put in front of the cameras by police
celebrating his life a vigil to mark the
one year anniversary
of george floyd's death as his family
meet the president
a very good morning to you this time
last year dominic cummings and boris
johnson worked together
fighting the covid pandemic but then
they fell out
now downing street is bracing itself as
the prime minister's former adviser
prepares to appear before mps this
morning to give
his side of the story about how the
government planned for the pandemic
he's already been tweeting his claims
and the government has denied many of
his allegations
our chief political correspondent john
craig reports
they were the closest of allies on
brexit in 2016
and in the general election in 2019
but after falling out spectacularly
after dominic cummings left downing
street at the end of last year
boris johnson and his former aide have
become sworn enemies
now tory mps fear mr cummings is hell
bent on revenge and out to destroy the
prime minister
i told the prime minister some time ago
that if he
didn't get rid of mr cummings then the
likelihood was that mr cummings would
bring him down
i still think that is possible and i
hold to that view
the twitter stream that's been coming
out from mr cummings
over recent days suggests that he
doesn't intend to take prisoners
mr cummings main allegation in tweets
over the past week
is that mr johnson cost thousands of
lives
by delaying lockdowns and pursuing a
policy of herd immunity
the government's chief scientific
advisor told sky news last year
that communities becoming immune to
coronavirus
was part of controlling it i mean what
sort of percentage of people
need to have contracted the virus
probably about 60 percent or so
and we think that this virus is likely
to be one that comes back year on year
become like a seasonal virus and
communities will become immune to it and
that's going to be an important part of
controlling this
longer term mr cummings demise began
with his lockdown busting trip to durham
last year
and his explanation in a downing street
news conference
my wife was very worried particularly
given my eyesight it seemed to
seem to have been affected by the
disease she did not want to risk
a nearly 300 mile drive with our child
given how ill i had been
we agreed that we should go for a short
drive to see if i could drive safely
we drove for roughly half an hour and
ended up on the outskirts of barnard
castle town
this former whitehall adviser sacked by
mr cummings
claims this time he'll be accused of
rewriting history
everybody has an agenda in westminster i
think what dominic cummings will come
out with is his version
of the truth i think he sincerely
believes everything he says and i think
he's bringing it out into the open
to get his point across and also to
damage boris johnson and the government
as much as possible
mr cummings made his name operating in
the shadows
today he'll be center stage john craig
sky news
[Applause]
and you can watch full coverage of that
appearance by dominic cummings from half
past nine this morning live here on sky
news well let's talk to the transport
secretary
grant chaps morning to you look i mean
how worried are you about what dominic
cummings might say
well i think he's probably tweeted most
of what he's um going to say already
um and meanwhile you know we're getting
on with the job as we can see we've got
vaccinations now running it and i'm just
looking on your own
ticker here over 44 percent of adults
have had both vaccinations over 70 well
over 70 have had
one vaccination and we're getting on top
of this thing and i think
that's only happened because of
decisions that were made more than a
year ago right at the beginning of this
pandemic where the prime minister put
money into research and development
building
manufacturing capacity uh and um and and
ensuring that we had this sort of
well-beating roll out of the vaccine
that we're all experiencing and
benefiting from now as a population
yeah but when we have to i mean everyone
would accept that mistakes were made i
mean
in in the the wake of of just the scale
of what this turned out to be
i mean that that's going to come as no
surprise to anyone but the mail saying
this morning
the prime minister offered to be
injected with covid on live tv to show
it was nothing to be
scared of is there any truth in that i i
think
you're right the first time which is
that you know uh we were making
decisions under
um unprecedented situation there's no
rule book there's no
there's no sort of textbook to sort of
open and see how to deal with a pandemic
the last time the world
faced anything like this was a 100 years
ago with the spanish flu
and so it's easy to be sort of
professors of hindsight
my you know what i'd say is i think on
the very big calls which are things like
developing
the vaccine and having a program in
place to roll it out
faster than any other major equivalent
economy
and being able to test now our entire
population twice a week everybody's
entitled to lateral flow tests
uh being able to sequence the genomes so
the science behind it i think all the
on those big things we got it right but
you're you know you're right the first
time
there was no rule book and of course
there would be mistakes made but you
know i i i think um
it it it's easy to sort of be the
professor of hindsight and look back on
it yeah but there's i mean to
to be to be fair there's there's nothing
wrong then is uh with with transparency
and admitting if
if if some things were done incorrectly
if
if you know if if bad decisions were
suggested
like you are being injected with covid
live on tv i mean
look if if if that's a mistake that was
made it's going to be helpful in
defusing this isn't it by admitting to
it
well i think the way to deal with it is
for a public inquiry which is what we've
announced will do
fully independent public inquiry which
will look into absolutely every aspect
of this
coronavirus so i think that's the the
right way to do it
uh and you know um i think it's like one
of the main
one of the central accusations is that
we know there
wasn't going to be another lockdown
whereas in fact we had two further
lockdowns after
um that apparent uh accusation in
october and we know we'd lock down in
november and and january
i mean d were only still coming out of
that last lockdown so i'd also say
let's look at what actually happened
rather than what somebody says was said
once in some
meeting and i think most people
kind of just understand that and
certainly when i meet people
they they say look we appreciate that
there's no
handbook to dealing with a pandemic and
for certain
there will have been things that we
could have done um differently and
actually particularly before the
pandemic we didn't have a production
facility for ppe for example in this
country
we were barely producing any of it at
all we didn't have
uh you know any facilities to test
virus which now we have about two
million tests today
but just to try to drag you back to the
dominant cummings thing why is he doing
what he's doing then why has he tweeted
what he's tweeted which we'll hear
repeated today
maybe more information on top is he just
a man spurned
well look i'll i'll i'll leave others to
determine how
reliable a witness to all this is and he
he was he was there at the time and what
his motives would would be i'll leave to
others
as i said i think what most people are
interested in is when are they getting
their second vaccine
if they haven't had it already or
whether they're getting their first one
if they're younger
and the good news on that is it will be
coming down to 30 yeah plus
uh this uh this week actually so you
know we're getting through the
population bringing it down
uh through the age groups and i think
that's what we'll be focusing most
people's attention
this week rather than a sideshow over
a former advisor who um has his own
agenda presumably
well not the first sideshow we've had
with dominic cummings i know
you know as ministers you get wheeled
out to do interviews like this one
whether you
whether you whether you want to or not
you were the first minister wheeled out
on the sunday morning shows
after we heard about dominic cummings in
his trip to barnard castle and then of
course your position was
to defend him you called it a perfectly
sensible
rational step he's attacking the
government now i mean
do you want to rethink that yes i think
this tie-up is entirely coincidental
i happen to be doing the press
conference that uh that that weekend and
uh and as you as you say uh was then
speaking about
um uh events um i mean
as with back then you know the reason
i'm actually on today is to talk about
401 million pounds of
investment in rail which will probably
matter
a lot more than a former advisor
being in front of a select committee to
the lives of your viewers so
you know we're upgrading further
upgrades actually to money i've
announced previously on the transparent
route for example
upgrades in in exeter uh and in
uh in thor park at stations uh and
these are real improvements to the
infrastructure of our country which will
probably make i mean
i'd love to talk about because they'll
probably actually make a real difference
to people's lives in this country and
come on top of massive reform of the
railway including the rail
white paper uh last week um so i mean if
you're if your question is sort of
edging out would i rather be talking
about
things that people actually care about
will matter to their lives and their
journeys then of course the answer is
yes
well yes well one that's what i'm
actually asking you is is is
do you actually think it was a
reasonable rational step
uh for dominic cummings to go to barnard
castle or now are you prepared
to say action actually you had to defend
him at the time but you didn't want to
but if i'm going on to defend news from
a year ago then that's like another
another matter
again i remember on that occasion i was
talking about a billion pounder this is
400 million today
something about billion pound upgrade uh
to the a66 and other
things roads that will matter to
people's lives as well look i don't want
to sort of dredge all over
the the the the past the uh the dominick
cummings trip to barnard castle i think
has been
covered uh in the media with more column
inches than than
uh than almost anything else as i say i
think that um
what people are going to really care
about is our
ongoing response to getting out of this
coronavirus
crisis um looking to complete the
the unlocks and you know some of these
great decisions on investment decisions
that we're making which will actually
help
people's journeys and people get about
that is the stuff that's going on yes
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely you are absolutely right
minister
it does matter and one of the things
that matters is how we deal with the
the indian variant which of course is is
a real concern it is a variant of
concern
um now angela rayner says the
the confusion around the advice that's
been given we're talking about it
yesterday about
this sort of travel restriction guidance
that was
given to eight of these key areas
affected by the
the india variant which you've now
rolled back on she's called it
dangerously incompetent but
why is she wrong on that well look we're
not first of all we're not imposing any
further
uh local lockdowns at the moment um
there's some additional advice and
guidance
um issued uh because common sense tells
you that if you're living in an area
which has
um an infection rate which is much
higher than the
national norm then it's sensible to
think about the steps and to remind
people about the steps that they should
um they should think about taking and
that's all it is yeah but
forgive forgive me for jumping in but
that's the key point in all of this
isn't it i mean we
we've heard a lot from you and others
about taking personal responsibility now
which makes a lot of sense to a lot of
people
how can people take personal
responsibility for a changing guidance
when they aren't aware there's been a
change in guidance
well to say i i it was put on the um on
the government website that these are
the additional steps that you
should be to remind ourselves of which
are all the usual things by the way you
know it's better to meet people outside
than inside keep the two metres apart
and the like
um so sort of common sense advice um it
was put up on the website
now now if the argument is uh the you
know could have been
um communicated better than than
actually i
i we think that's that that's the case
and we'll certainly have a look at the
way that that's
communicated in the future we had
actually spoken to the local health
authorities and
uh the idea was it for it to be
communicated on a local level
but as the the vaccine minister said
yesterday in in the house
um if there are better ways to
communicate that we'll we'll look at
doing that
but really you know we're in a position
now
where thanks to the extraordinary
efforts of
everybody in the nhs the amazing ability
to
coronavirus test up to two million
people per
day in this country the vaccine rollout
we're getting on top of these things i
think if we didn't
offer any guidance help support advice
people would rightly say
why haven't you said anything and uh and
you know it was up on the
on the website you know if the
accusation is um could you go further
uh on these things then i think that's
probably right but the key thing is
this is not a new lockdown these are not
new laws
it's just a piece of advice okay look um
there was a report yesterday about
islamophobia within the conservative
party that i mean we know the party said
it's going to take on board
all the recommendations it said that the
anti-muslim sentiment
remains a problem within the
conservative party
presumably by accepting the
recommendations the party
uh agrees with that sentiment does it so
how do you how do you move to combat
that
yes i don't think there's any room in
a modern political party for any form of
discrimination of any type whatsoever
and and in fact in society and you know
in political parties just as
in society sometimes you'll get these
incidents
and the way that they're investigated in
the way that they're handled is um is
is really really important which is why
we asked for this fully independent
report to be drawn up we've accepted all
27 i think it is recommendations uh
behind the report
uh and we will enact them um all because
um
you know this is a party which is a big
broad wide
open party that wants people from every
single
different background different parts of
the country
uh and and uh and you know we couldn't
be clearer
uh about that so um you know i i i
my view is it's always best to be open
about it
get this report and then act on it which
is exactly what we're gonna do
well i mean you've got six weeks to come
up with by your own timetable six weeks
to come up with with an action
plan on on that on the back of baroness
farsi saying that it shows the party's
institutionally racist
well i i i thought it was a surprising
thing to say because baroness farsi is
actually
a former chairman of the uh of the party
we um
we and that's not what the report said
as well the reports that the party's
certainly not
institutionally racist it did say that
there are problems with the way that
um sometimes complaints are dealt with
although it also said
this isn't specific to uh complaints
about islamophobia
the party structure any party's
structure tends to be
a bit unusual as much as you have a
central party but then you also have
effectively 650 local parties
in every part of the country
constituencies in every part of the
country and so and they're run by local
volunteers
and so there are doubtless and i think
that's what the report
highlights ways to improve all of that
both centrally and
locally and that's exactly what we'll do
we you know as i said
absolutely there is no space for any
form
of uh phobia in the conservative party
let me jump let me jump in and i'm sorry
to do so but we are really
pushing against the clock and your
people want you to move on i know
um can we end on some good news it looks
like is it right
that we're going to get green light
which we might not be getting green
light for greece
or for for spain necessarily but but the
the islands the canary islands balieri
islands greek islands
may be heading onto the green list soon
is that right well we will have to wait
for the joint biosecurity center to
uh to provide um their readout from all
of this
i think that story which i saw on the
front of one of the papers today
just comes from the fact that we've
always said in the past
and have tried to assess islands
separately
whether that's possible or not isn't
just down to the level of infection
on those islands it's also down to their
abilities for example to sequence the
genomes that we know about
the variance and potential variance of
concern on those islands as well
so not to disappoint you and your
viewers and the next review
is that the first week in june so i'm
not very far away and i'm afraid we will
have to
wait until then not least steve because
actually i don't have that information
from the joint biosecurity center
who are still carrying out that work in
order to make sure it's as up-to-date as
possible
we will be waiting with baited breath of
course so good to see you this morning
thank you
you're welcome now still to come on the
program we're going to hear from two
former number 10 advisers one labour one
tory as dominic cummings prepares to
tell us his version of what we're doing
in downing street at the height of the
pandemic
30 year olds have had to call up for
their vaccines but there's new concern
about blood clots we'll talk to a
specialist at 7 45
and at five past eight we'll hear from
the shadow foreign secretary lisa nandy
ahead of dominic cummings appearance
before that parliamentary committee
now the authorities in belarus have
released a video of the girlfriend of
the dissident journalist
roma protestovic sofia sepaiga was taken
off the ryanair plane forced to divert
to minsk
and arrested at the same time as her
boyfriend
i am sophia sopiga andredna i was born
on the 10th of february 1998.
i am citizen of the russian federation i
live in lithuania vilnius
on 23rd of may 2001 i flew on the same
plane with roman protisovic
thought by europe correspondent adam
parsons who's in brussels what are we to
make of this video adam
well it's the second video of course
released by the belarusian
uh authorities roman procedures video
was the first this
uh is his girlfriend and i think they
have put them out
as an attempt to do two things one is on
the face of it
to offer reassurance that these two
people are alive and in one piece
but the second really is to say to the
world
and to say to dissidents in belarus here
we are
these people opposed us and look where
they are now
in captivity and facing a form
of justice uh i spoke yesterday to a man
called stephan poteglio who
is the co-founder of the next
channel alongside romero impressive
uh and he said that he was getting
death threats pretty much every day and
he regarded that this arrest
and this process of bringing the
airliner down in menskanda what i think
most people now agree to be forced
pretenses
as being an effort by the government of
alexander lukachenko to intimidate him
and other opponents of the regime and
also to demonstrate the strength that mr
lukashenko
thinks that he has to control uh any
dissident forces now
the european union the uk and the wider
world the united states
have reacted with absolute shock
revulsion and discuss
this process endorsing the idea that
this was a hijacker
an air piracy a kidnapping
but in a sense mr lukashenko seems to
have already found himself in a corner
regarded as a rogue leader
and dismissed as an illegitimate leader
this is a message he's sending out to
dissidents
in his own country that he cannot
be brought down easily and this video
clearly filmed under some form of duress
is part of that jigsaw
okay adam thank you hundreds of
excuse me hundreds of people held a
vigil last night to celebrate the life
of george floyd on the one year
anniversary of his murder
his family met president biden and
called for america to work together to
make sure people no longer live in fear
helen ann smith reports from minneapolis
[Music]
a man his death and a story that shocked
the world
and shook america
[Applause]
george floyd and what happened here is
now so symbolic of an age-old american
struggle
a grief and a grievance still far from
resolved
this place has left its mark upon
history even if there's a way still to
go
for the floyd family that brings comfort
and pride
amidst today wrought with emotion i
think
if we had just had him pass away or die
and nothing happened as a result of it
it
you know it would have felt like it was
not worth the pain
and suffering and don't get me wrong i
definitely wish i could have him back
but since we can't
this is nice to be able to see all of
the people who are in support of us
other members of the family went to
washington the president paid tribute to
their extraordinary courage and said
america had to take action
they'd all hoped police reform
legislation would be passed by today
if you can make federal laws to protect
the bird
which is the bald eagle you can make
federal laws to protect people of color
say his name george floyd
in what was once an ordinary junction
they commemorated
and celebrated the young and the old
together
but there's tension here too born from
decades of brutality
and a sense that not enough's changed
amidst the carnival atmosphere here
there's a tentative sense of hope too
a feeling that just maybe this time
tragedy and trauma
might lead to meaningful change
all night i do it for george floyd
it will be hard fought but the eyes of
the world are still watching
as they were just one year ago
[Applause]
this is reflection and remembrance in a
remarkable place
where history's been made and they want
to make more
helena smith sky news minneapolis
and tonight you can watch a special
program looking at the wider issue of
racial equality in the wake of mr
floyd's death that's george floyd from
murder
to justice nine o'clock tonight here on
sky news
now a key question around the
anniversary of george floyd's death is
whether conversations around race and
inequality taking place in the uk
are actually improving people's lives
sky news is launching a new project
today
to actually address this let's talk to
our home editor jason farrell what's
happening jason
well a group of academics from the
center on the dynamics of ethnicity
and the sky news data team are working
together and launching a new project to
try and find out about the data gaps
in our knowledge what we've discovered
is actually there's quite a lot of
things we don't know about the range of
diverse groups
living in the uk and these academics
feel that that
could lead to poor policy decisions
those gaps in our knowledge so for
example on mental health there's not
really
any single study that cross-sections the
outcomes mental health outcomes of
people
by their ethnicity these academics have
looked at old studies for example
admissions
to mental health wards and found that
actually if you're black you're five
times more likely to have a serious
mental
health problem than if you're white so
why is that
could there be a better study on that
equally
if you're looking at the vaccination
program for example and health
in the bangladeshi community there was a
study that found that
20 percent of people over the age of 50
to 50 to 59
thought that they had poor health but at
a separate study
on white people it doesn't get to that
level until they get to in their
80s 80 to 89. so um
these two these academics feel be a
single study that looks at those kind of
things
and also not just lumping ethnic groups
in
necessary as having one single
experience so for example what is the
difference between
the experiences of people living in
rural areas compared
to living in the city a lot of our
surveys on
black ethnic minorities for example look
at what's going on in cities
but a quarter of a million people from
ethnic minorities live in rural areas if
you look for example
stop at search figures you're 23 times
more likely to be stopped and searched
if you're black in dorset
than if you're white whereas it's only
four times more in london
so these are the kind of things that
they're going to look at let's hear from
dr nissa finney who's one of the
academics who's working on this
it will also cover topics and aspects of
life
and that are relatively unknown about
for minority communities
such as political attitudes financial
health and mental health and well-being
religious and ethnic identities
so it's going to be called the evidence
on equality national
survey it's going to cover 20 000 people
it should be reporting before the end of
the year and we'll be across what it
finds
okay jason thank you you can see the
full story on sky news from five o'clock
tonight and people from minority ethic
and religious groups can find out more
about the survey and how to take part
at even survey dot co
dot uk
now a dutch court will rule today on a
landmark court case which could force
the oil giant shell to cut co2 emissions
by
almost half by 2030. climate activist
groups want the company to align its
policies
with the climate goals set out in the
paris agreement shell which says it
plans to go
net zero by 2050 or sooner says court
action
will not accelerate the transition from
fossil fuels
and of course you can watch the daily
climate show here on sky news half past
six and a half past nine
every weekday
police in northamptonshire have arrested
three people after the death of a 16
year old boy
in corby police officers were called to
reports of a stabbing in constable road
but the force said
despite the best efforts of paramedics
the boy died
at the scene the foreign secretary
will meet israeli and palestinian
leaders today as he visits jerusalem and
the occupied west bank as parts of
efforts to maintain a ceasefire
between israel and hamas mr raab will be
pushing the uk
support for a two-state solution
well this is sky news breakfast let's
see what's happening in the weather for
you today joe any better
yes better not completely better yet
we've still got the effects of this
area of low pressure affecting us but as
we go towards the back holiday weekend
high pressure building in so we see more
subtle conditions
and it will get warmer as well let's
take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
we're not quite out of the woods yet
because
this is still associated with the area
of low pressure which is pushing away
uh crossing denmark now so still a
little bit unsettled
as we go through the course of the day
but we will see more in the way of
sunshine
drier conditions and higher temperatures
too
so first thing this morning it's a
little bit gray over much of scotland
northeastern parts of england
here we've got some rain and that's
going to be working its way southwards
through the course of the day
but it's dying out as it goes so for a
while we will turn
rather cloudy in parts and elsewhere
after a bright start cloud will bubble
up
and we'll see a few showers developing
too one or two of these could be
on the heavy side with the odd rumble of
thunder but temperatures up to around 18
or 19 degrees celsius at best at 66
degrees fahrenheit
through the course of the afternoon that
area of cloud
makes its way down into parts of east
anglia but it is fizzling out as it goes
and certainly as we go through this
evening
and overnight many of these showers will
disappear nice bright start for most
tomorrow morning away from eastern coast
a bit murky
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast from fen
friend to foe dominic cummings set to
give a
scathing review of boris johnson's
handling of the pandemic to mps today
finance financial institutions which are
at the heart of the uk economy
are also at the heart of the uk carbon
economy and there's
no way you can take climate change
seriously in the uk until we start to
get
a grip on the emissions that are not
just enabled but actually directly
financed
by uk financial institutions the
millions and millions of pounds that
they make available through
loans uh syndicated loan arrangements to
the investments
uh in in companies literally uh around
the world
uh is the capital it's the money that
keeps those companies
uh and those emitters going um without
that finance
without the support of those financial
institutions there's absolutely no way
that any of that activity could take
place now nobody's saying that you have
to turn it off overnight
uh nobody is saying that there is uh you
know that there isn't going to be
transition period but the reality is
we've got about 10 years
to almost half our carbon emissions
between now
and 2030 uh to reach the goals of the
paris agreement the uk government's been
very clear
they want to be leader in this space if
you want to be a leader in this space
they have to get a grip on the uk's um
single um biggest thing they could
probably do
to to to reduce our carbon emissions in
that time
one of the really amazing things that
this study shows
is that the reach of uk financial
institutions
goes far beyond uk borders and the uk
finance emissions are far bigger
almost twice as big as uk's direct
emissions
so that is possibly our most direct
relationship
to the global problem is how we finance
it around the world
there are going to have to be rules with
regular milestones that are both checked
and enforced by government to make sure
we get there as a sector
as a country as a whole
[Music]
[Music]
now downing street is bracing itself as
the prime minister's former advisor
dominic cummings prepares to appear
before mps this morning to give
his side of the story about how the
government planned for the pandemic
a few minutes ago i spoke to the
transport secretary who called mr
cummings appearance
a sideshow i'll leave others to
determine how
reliable a witness to all this is and he
he was he was there at the time and what
his motives would would be i'll leave to
others
as i said i think what most people are
interested in is when are they getting
their second vaccine
if they haven't had it already or when
are they getting their first one if
they're younger
and the good news on that is it will be
coming down to 30 yeah plus
uh this uh this week actually so you
know we're getting through the
population bringing it down
uh through the age groups and um i think
that's what we'll be focusing most
people's attention
this week rather than a side show over
um a former advisor who
has his own agenda presumably
i said to downing street in our
political correspondent tomorrow cohen i
mean it's interesting isn't it it's more
about
what grant chapter doesn't say than what
he does there
yes that's right stephen and while he
seemed to be brushing it off saying
we're looking to the future this is
someone who was damaged
by his explanations for going to barnard
castle and
acting as if uh the government are just
powering on ahead uh there are there are
nerves behind the scenes about what
dominic cummings will say today he's not
just any disgruntled
former employee he was the prime
minister's chief advisor he was sitting
in those meetings
when the fateful decisions were made
leading up to the first and second
lockdowns
last year and we know from what he's
been writing on twitter over the last
few days
that his contention is that he was
pushing for an
early lockdown and a tough lockdown to
get a grip on the virus
and he claims that it was the prime
minister who was dithering who was
delaying
who was making what dominic cummings
calls awful decisions
which led to the deaths potentially of
tens of thousands
of people now we don't know what dominic
cummings is going to bring with him to
those mps will it just be his word
against the prime ministers will he have
documents or emails to back up what he's
saying
but of course while dominic cummings
will be asked whether he showed us any
of the responsibility
for these poor decisions there will be
nerves behind the scenes
about what damaging details might come
out
okay thank you let's talk to john
mcternan former top level labour party
advisor and sir craig oliver the former
communications director at number 10
when david cameron was prime minister
good to see you both this morning craig
just how damaging could this be do you
think
well like i think so much of politics is
expectation management and i think that
dominic cummings over the last few days
has raised the bar for what he has to
achieve today he clearly wants to do
some damage to the prime minister he
clearly wants to make out
the government wasn't competent and the
boris johnson took the wrong choices
but a lot of information is already out
there we've had this
discussion for a very long time and
we've also had a number of elections
recently where it seems many many people
were prepared to give the benefit of the
doubt to the government
so i'm not saying that he won't do some
damage today but i think that it's
probably going to be more noisy than
effective
i mean is there a sense john that people
will just see this
as a man with an agenda
depends what he says doesn't it i think
craig is right about that and
the key is uh this isn't just any
adviser
of the you know the of the hundreds that
our government has over its lifetime
this is a man who was in the room uh he
was in the room for
all of the critical decisions um and he
at the time he was in number 10 he was
regarded as
the key advisor the chief adviser the
svengali the one who knew
exactly what the prime minister wanted
what the prime minister was doing at any
one time
and i think that's the interest for
anybody who cares about politics is
why were the decisions made the way they
were
um you know what did it's like any
inquiry
what did the prime minister know when
and what does he do as a consequence and
i think we have
uh well the common select committee has
a chance today to
answer those questions will it impact on
the public who knows but it will
definitely bring
new information to light and i think it
will possibly pivot around
this thing that dominic's come back to
again again and his twitter thread which
is
was there a strategy of herd immunity
that was then abandoned
but wasn't explained as being abandoned
um because this government does
say it does one thing then changes and
never says it changed it just keeps on
plowing on the questions uh what will
the revealing of the discussions
internally do for the government
i mean in terms of that herd immunity
policy
i mean we know from from my interview
with the the chief scientific advisor
in march last year craig i mean it was
certainly something
they were looking at that's going to be
very hard to deny isn't it
yeah i think it's certainly going to be
very hard to deny i also remember when
we were discussing this uh at the time
that there was a lot of stories in the
newspapers saying that it was actually
something that dominic cummings thought
was worthy of considering
and i think that's gonna be one of his
difficulties today he's somebody who has
said
and set himself up when he was in
government as the most powerful figure
there
that he was running the show he was in
charge and i suspect you'll get quite a
lot of questions about well hang on a
minute
weren't you supposed to actually be in
the room and directing some of this
stuff
and i also think it's interesting that
you see what grand chapters tactic there
was
i think he's going to try and the
government will try and present him as
somebody who's disgruntled and
disgruntled and discredited he is
remember the person in the public
consciousness
who basically broke the rules that he
was involved in setting
and then thought it was a good idea to
have an eye test by driving his car
around
that's a credibility problem and i think
that on top of that there's another
credibility problem of
hang on a minute mate you were actually
in the room so he's gonna have to come
up to something i think
a lot more than was the government
pursuing herd immunity
because frankly i think people will say
we've heard all about that and we've
made our decision already
yeah but in terms of that credibility
problem craig i mean it isn't part of
the
the issue with that is that when all
that was kicking off and people were
furious about it
the prime minister was staunchly
defending him it was and i
think that this is what's interesting is
you can keep talking about it and you
can keep going back to the past and you
can point out that was wrong that was a
problem
the public aren't fools they saw all
that it was all over the media it was
all
over programs like sky news and they
were able to make a decision at the
ballot box very recently
i don't want to dismiss the seriousness
of this but i think it's really
important to make a distinction between
what the media considers to be extremely
important and is going to cause damage
and what the public actually consider
and at the end of the day i think it's
going to have taken an
awful lot more than has actually come
out so far and what's hinted is going to
be coming out
to do real damage yeah i mean that's
part of the problem for the labour party
in all of this john
isn't it i mean is is there actually
anything they can capitalize on here or
indeed would want to capitalize on
oh look i'm never and never interfere
with your enemy uh
when they're attacking themselves uh so
i think the labour party will stand back
from this
but also i think the law party will will
seek to draw
a line between the policy last year
the confusion the changes the briefing
the lack of clarity on communications
and what's happening at the moment you
know are there
um are the local are the local travel
bans or aren't there
um they were announced then they've been
de-announced and i think
that confusion uh in communications the
hesitation about the lockdown
private sector companies were locking
down before the government locked down
so i think it reminds people of that and
look this time last year
grant shops would have been wheeled out
and all the other client mint
cabinets were wheeled out to defend
dominic coming so
uh the it's what's revealing um is the
behavior of the loyal cabinet ministers
who are media performers
last year they've been they've been
defending dom and this year they're
this year they're attacking him um and
some of it will come through
it's bit by bit is the way that you um
make a case
from opposition about the government and
this is this is a bit more
uh another of all yep but if you were
if you were advising kia starmajan at
the moment i mean what would you be
saying to him because
there's a danger here isn't there for
the labor party they adopted this
sort of constructive critical support if
you like of what was happening and
approved
and agreed with a lot of the actions
that the government took in the
very height of the pandemic i mean they
could put themselves in the firing line
if they're too critical couldn't they
oh look in the end um craig's right
the public will make their minds up
about this i don't believe
that the the the recent elections in
early may
or a referendum on the conduct of the
pandemic
they're a referendum on boris johnson
which he which which he did really well
in
as he did in the general election he's
incredibly popular
uh politician with a very very deep
reach uh into many traditional labour
voters
the labour party has to allow the public
to make their mind up about the totality
of the handling
uh of the pandemic um you can't lead the
public to a conclusion
what you can do is focus on things
which show something about the character
and the judgment of the government and
so
what can we tell at the moment we can
tell they're as confused in their
messaging
uh about blackburn uh and bolton
as they were last year about was it her
immunity or not in her divinity
there's something about their
unwillingness to change their mind or to
admit they got made a mistake
now at the moment that doesn't matter it
will matter over the long run so you
build a case over time
and it politics will come back as normal
by the end of the year
when we're out of the pandemic and we're
into unemployment
okay look we've got to leave it there
john mcternan and sir craig oliver it's
good to talk to you both this morning
thank you
thank you and let me know what you think
at sky stephen
do you care about this or would you
rather focus on what is happening to get
out of the pandemic and the vaccinations
and what have you as
as grant shaps was saying earlier on
love to hear your thoughts this morning
now when the pandemic hit film and tv
production or a lot of it at least was
shut down with companies forced to find
new technologies and locations in order
to get cameras rolling again but now
some of those temporary measures look
like
they could become the new normal here's
our entertainment reporter
claire gregory
[Music]
when lockdown hit the film and tv
industry needed a game plan to satisfy
the ever-growing appetites of
content hungry audiences
for live sport fans suddenly unable to
fill stadiums the pandemic spelled
disaster
but a tactical move to remote production
5g sim cards and delivering via the
cloud
means sky sports has aired more than 100
live netball games since covid broke out
compared to only 20 the previous year
we've certainly had some unexpected
challenges along the way the recent
social media boycott meant we had to
adapt very quickly
to deliver via the cloud on those front
channels
um but it's really meant that we're in a
situation where this hopefully will
become business as usual and we can roll
it out across a number of our sports
from live sport to high-end drama for
productions forced to minimize
crews or unable to access certain
locations the rollout of new
virtual production technology used on
the mandalorian
has accelerated as he moves the camera
around the perspective actually changes
so um you know previously we were just
using the wall as a backdrop
but now you can kind of see as he moves
around
that square on the screen there will
update with it so if we were to sort of
you know walk around slightly and move
you can kind of see how we're not
just standing against a backdrop we're
actually in
a 3d space one of the advantages to this
technology
is that the screens can be almost
instantly changed at the touch of a
button
so a production can move from a factory
in russia like this
to a bar in nashville like this without
moving location
while covert travel restrictions have
meant many countries favored by
filmmakers haven't been available
not all actors have to completely
abandon their ambition to travel
as a covert safe location the caribbean
island of nevis has signed a two-picture
deal
launching the film industry there a lot
of people are unable to go to location
now
so we're able to bring the locations to
them the tv and film industry may have
been forced to adapt because of the
pandemic
but with some of the new options
benefiting not just the productions
themselves but also
the environment thanks to the reduced
carbon footprint the changes are likely
to be around
long after restrictions left claire
gregory sky news
all of this is real just to let you know
this is sky news breakfast still to come
we're going to be talking to a leading
specialist about vaccines
for 30 year olds and the new warning
about the risk of blood clots
[Music]
oh
only about half a mile from the turkish
coast and
it's evident that is the boat seriously
overcrowded
this is one of the most severe viruses
in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in istanbul
that's it it got us then
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
[Music]
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
her arms look at her arms i can put my
entire hand round
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
[Music]
and once it takes hold it's very very
difficult for these
firefighters to get a grip of it and get
on top of it and put it out
[Music]
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
fantastic
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to the
safety ridge holiday podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free okay let's talk about the
vaccines and talk to dr
maggie weymouth who's the gp who sits on
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization it's really good to see you
this morning
first and foremost what i mean what's
your view on on the vaccine uptake
at the moment i mean very well in a lot
of age groups a lot of categories
obviously as we move down the age group
is there any concern
well we are doing fantastically well um
with this rollout
i'm one day a week gp but i also do some
vaccination
and and the um the the the
the courage and and the enthusiasm
and and the people um waiting outside i
i do a mobile vaccination unit
and i have people um queuing across a
park in
brighton waiting to be vaccinated um
and and people are just very very keen
to have this vaccine they know what the
risks
are in terms of um protecting themselves
and and other people and they're really
keen to have this we we've given
60 million doses of various vaccines
over 30 million of astrazeneca
and people have got confidence in this
vaccine
because they realize just how dangerous
the coronavirus is
and they realize that having the vaccine
and two vaccines
is much more safe than taking a chance
and not having the vaccine at all
forgive me for interrupting but i mean
the problem that we are seeing in
particular with the indian variant it
would seem to be that a lot of the
the hospitalization inc in places like
bolton and blackburn and and and these
sort of hot spots
as we call them would seem to be from
people who should have been vaccinated
so there is
still a hesitancy issue among some
groups there are
some places where there was hesitancy in
first and these people have not been
vaccinated when they were eligible
so our message is if you're eligible
even if this was
weeks ago you should go and get your
first dose
there are some people who were worried
there was fake news being spread around
particularly towards our muslim
colleagues and
people took that seriously and sadly the
fake news
was given more credibility than
government advice
so the question is that we must reach
out
to the vulnerable groups who were
eligible months ago and remain
vulnerable what do we can i ask what do
we know about the state of vaccines
at this stage in regard to something
like the india variant
we see there seems to be an agreement
that they are somewhat effective do we
know how effective
well the the recent results are actually
incredibly
encouraging both for astrazeneca and for
the fight sir
um but the stress is on having two two
vaccine jabs that's the most important
thing is completing
the program we know that there's
slightly reduced efficacy for
um fight serve from 93 to 88
but this is still extraordinarily good
in terms of vaccine experience
and the um efficacy for
astrazeneca has dropped from 66 to 60
but on a population basis this is
extraordinary
because we know that both of these
vaccines actually reduce transmission
so that by taking two jabs um one is
protecting oneself but one is also
protecting one's loved ones and
the community around you yeah look just
if i can in 30 seconds
should we see the vaccine particularly
in hot spot areas rolled out to younger
people to 18s and over
well we we are moving down the ages
but we are concentrating on the
vulnerable people
because those are the people who will if
they catch it they will
be hospitalized so the program is right
we are just
increasing the speed but we should be
moving down the ages in the correct
order and still concentrating on the
vulnerable older people who we know will
end up in hospital if they're not
vaccinated
dr williams we're just changing the
speed yeah look
we're out of time it's really good to
talk to you thank you
okay quick check on the weather for you
with joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you what we
haven't seen the last of the rather damp
weather but things
are improving and certainly the bank
holiday weekend is looking pretty good
this morning not too bad but we do have
this area of cloud and rain
over parts of scotland northeastern
england and that's going to be working
its way southwards through the day
it is breaking up as it goes and
eventually in the sunnier spots we'll
see temperatures up to around 19 degrees
celsius
that's 66 degrees fahrenheit could be a
few showers around and where they do
occur could be quite heavy
with some thunder most of those showers
and a lot of the day's cloud
will also disappear as we go into this
evening and overnight
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
you